I'm not necessarily trying to find a
different angle I'm just trying to
convey what's in my head I guess
I'm Natalie Hartley and I'm the fashion
director for Glamour magazine the job
that I do entails organizing the fashion
team and I style all the fashion shoots
and the celebrity cover shoots as well
do you guys want to come around and
we'll have a look at what we're doing
today and the idea is the puffer jacket
and I've got here a small mood board
that we can show you the looks and the
whole thing is maybe slightly 80s and
there's lots of color volumous and want
to try and keep things I guess the
opposite of that with her makeup with
what the bright colors you want to
connect you don't want it to be too busy
like with the makeup and the hair
southies again it's this is a great
reference I think it might be nice to
maybe smooth it out a little you know to
make it like so it's more narrow and
obviously makes a slightly narrower
silhouette that sounds perfect
another li hi Greg how are you Allah yes
very good thank you
have you got some more puffers that have
come in we do yeah amazing yeah I'd love
to have a look so what we do for glamour
is try and make things fashion inspired
but still wearable I try and make things
interesting turn it on his head a bit
yeah that looks amazing I love that so
wrong it's right that is kind of the
brief of the day it's so bad that it's
good let's try the PS de resistance
let's keep any other yeah exactly I want
people with personalities I look for
that in models that they feel a story
and with Madison you always get back oh
wow yeah she kind of put things on and
she becomes a character and I love that
in her okay we're ready to shoot I want
to just catch you doing stuff yeah so
like catching me in between a moment not
posed
most people would not put these things
together but I'm hoping that them by
seeing them that they might actually go
yeah I might actually try that you can
just enjoy and be confident and there
isn't any rules anymore have fun with
them that's great
that's great there's some really good
ones on them you really like chaterino
yeah no no I don't really like to
overthink anything I think the whole
thing of shoots is to keep the energy
going and everyone feels like they're
excited and not lifted by all okay so I
was thinking of these the top floors
yeah yeah I think that's brilliant mean
I love that from the back so should we
get rid of one of these ones here so
yeah we'll lose that maybe we can go a
little bit tighter on something like
that do you think yes that's a really
strong shot yeah brilliant she's ready
yeah the unpredictability of it all
never really knowing what's gonna be the
final outcome that was quite nice it
just comes to you I guess it is very
hard to explain that you just want to
kind of keep it in the moment
you
I absolutely love my job let's get on
with it I'm so excited about this you
never stop learning I like things to be
effortless not to try hard I want every
picture to stand on its own